yeah i accidentally stepped on this hurt
what up gq my name is dominic chambroni
also known as the shoe surgeon soon to
be the surgeon
[Music]
even before making custom shoes i was
customizing anything building forts
actually like making i remember the data
supremes i think it was like seventh or
eighth grade picking up some data
supremes taking them to school and then
just coloring on them with the orange
sharpie
and then after like getting those my
freshman year of high school my cousin
let me wear the original 85 of jordan's
i went to school wearing these shoes and
it just attracted people instantly where
they're like yo what are those shoes by
wearing those shoes it just like made me
think that i can actually speak without
actually having to talk
it was just something that gave me power
and instantly i knew i needed
shoes that made me feel good
i do know moving down to la from the bay
area
was
amazing for me it's what i needed to
make this business bigger than what it
was up in the garage so
coming down here you have celebrities
you have artists music athletes they
respect art and fashion and sneakers or
at least can afford them when i started
like collecting sneakers in high school
it was not just like
it wasn't just the jordans you know got
into the sb
for the storytelling my interest from
collecting shoes became about materials
and and sewing machines i wanted a
better sewing machine so i could make a
better shoe
first celebrity that i worked with was
will i am and then i drove down to la
and hand delivered them to him and then
i met justin bieber silas and then i
just started doing all of justin
bieber's tour because justin bieber was
popping so
these ones right here
i did for his tour jeremy scott never
did the all gold and they didn't have
his size so it's so funny to see it
because these are actually justin
bieber's i mean i did over 15 pairs of
shoes for him in the course of two years
it was cool to work with the superstar
the way i look at the art that we do is
just kind of like graffiti but shoes
happen to be
the canvas i saw kanye wearing the
balenciaga jacket at the chicago
performance and i just put it together
you know i saw the jacket it's easy so i
was like yo we got to do the shoe and we
made a shoe and then next thing you know
two chains hits us up that he wants a
pair he's on a cover wearing a pair this
shit's heavy but they're actually really
comfortable i wore these in vegas for a
couple days and it's one of the most
comfortable pairs of shoes
the most expensive shoe
that
we've made was the 250 000 repair of
collaboration with jason beverly hills
and it was the off-white one with hermes
croc pj tucker wore them into game five
last year and then they had the zip tie
like the off-white zip tie we made
actual bracelet with gold and diamonds
in it we're actually working on the most
expensive pair of sneakers in the world
it's going to be the air mags they're
going to be worth well over 2 million so
it's custom air mags auto lacing big ass
diamonds on each of them in the back of
the pack and then a system where you can
press a button and it can lace them so
it's working on the technology with the
shoe plus adding you know diamonds
[Music]
we're working on a 150 000 cleat for
odell beckham right now the golden
diamond
yellow gold with the diamonds in the
swoosh cooper cup an off-white dunk with
the the rams colorway i found an a cause
dress shirt at dover street cut it up
and put it into a pair of cleats for him
von miller we're taking the crazy one
kobe and turning it into his cleat and
then we got jalen and one is the
lombardi trophy so it looks like a
mirror when he wears them and then we're
doing some swarovski rhinestone ones
with dan life because we did a custom
helmet as well
this
is
a shoe we made a pizza pie top two so we
had a collaboration with pizza hut where
we produced some of these shoes for the
march madness commercial grant hill was
in it it's a completely original shoe
you know it kind of looks like a supreme
kind of looks like reebok nike and we
produced 250 pairs of these this one was
cool because you actually pressed the
button and order the pizza we've worked
with nike on projects with lebron james
we did collaborations with jordan brand
and did workshops in chicago with them
for the jordan 13. so yeah i look
forward to continuing to build
my cousin she's older she had an
original pair of 1985 jordan ones then i
found someone that said they could sell
them so i gave him a pair and then he
lost them how do you lose an original
pair of 85 and then he gave me 300 bucks
for it this is what we had to track down
it's the same size it could be the same
pair i don't even know but sorry cousin
for losing your shoes man i don't even
have time to make shoes for myself like
we're so busy like you know where a lot
of my my jordans now my old ones that
are dirty um because i like wearing my
[ __ ]
right now we're in the client experience
room this is a vip room where we only
bring our top clients you're in surgeon
headquarters 16 000 square feet we got a
full basketball court this is where you
produce all the shoes we got a full bar
we have a private lounge a lot of people
when they see the brand through
instagram they just think of a shoe they
think of an expensive shoe the surgeon
is more a title of a company that can do
anything we're going to be doing
furniture clothing you can light a
candle you can design a shoe you can
design a piece of furniture you can play
basketball soccer whatever it is that's
the world that we're gonna see in the
studio is like you get to see things
being made by hand start to finish we do
everything here i'm grateful with what
nike and jordan were able to do and i
just happened to be a part of the moment
and it's sparking my interest
to find something creative to fulfill
you know myself because life was very
hard and it i could have went down a
very different road you know dealing
with mental health dealing with
depression or whatever you want to call
it i put all of that energy into the
craft of shoemaking and it just
so be it happens you know to be a jordan
that kind of helped get me into that
space so thanks for having me gq you're
in the vip room so you get the first
real look to see the whole space so uh
you're welcome and we'll see you soon